i define the support class as a role
that further enhances the team's
effectiveness through buffs and/or
sustainability these are an undervalued
role within the team they're not always
required roles but they do make groups
faster make the fighting easier and
often a lot more fun when it comes to
the most difficult content in the game
these are the roles that are going to
help you get through it
I was going to create a support build
based on one of the more popular options
technicians Authority but when I was
thinking about it there's actually quite
a few options available so instead I'm
going to briefly run through a few of
the different support sets and what role
they play if there is a specific role
you'd like me to go into a little more
detail on just let me know in the
comments all sits in the division can be
placed into following groups please note
that this is based on the current 1.8
patch and the full 6 piece bonus that
each set has this is also based on my
experience with each set and there is
certainly a bit of gray area between
each of these groups which other sets
could fall but regardless I still feel
this is a good place to start in this
video we're going to talk about the
support group I'm going to briefly go
over each set in the different ways they
can fill the support role each of these
sets offer different bonuses so I'm
going to further break this down into
the following subgroups healer support
buff support crowd control and of course
emotional support again this is based on
the native bonuses that each set gives
but with the right skills and talents
each of these can run across multiple
subgroups we covered the healer support
role in the last video so we won't be
talking about this and as far as the
emotional support goes there isn't
really a build for this just try to be
there for them offering them a virtual
shoulder to cry on and if all else fails
maybe just find them a good counselor or
something the role of the buff support
is to provide increased damage and or
defensive bonuses to the team
particularly useful and in-game
activities like heroic incursions or
legendary missions where the enemies had
harder and take more damage the crowd
support player is there to slow or take
down large groups of enemies ideal for
slowing down the rate of NPC advancement
these builds are best suited and
activities like resistance or pretty
much anywhere that rushes are catching
your team off-guard
the tactician Authority Sepp is the most
all-round support set
I don't really rate the six piece set
very highly but using the four or five
piece set with something like the
inventive backpack or Barrett's chest
will have you gaining a decent amount of
utility with the one to five set piece
bonuses going directly into skill haste
and skill power thus it gives the most
flexibility in regards to skills crowd
control skills could include the be FB
sticky bomb flashbang sticky bomb either
the air burst or cluster CQ mines and
the flame turret buff skills include
smart cover tactical scanner pulse or
booster shot the reason that this is one
of the most popular choices as a support
role set is because of the flexibility
players can easily and quickly chop and
change between skills depending on the
situation and activity being played
the final measure four piece bonus
states win and range of hostile grenades
and waters diffuses them and adds
grenades to your inventory this alone is
a huge help and considering the massive
amount of grenade spam this game has
this build can be put together in a
couple of different ways focusing
heavily on skill power or firearms so
try this out based on your play style
preference myself I still like to be
able to do some weapon damage so
firearms is my go-to but this doesn't
mean you can't get any support utility
out of your skills skills like flashbang
sticky bomb and booster shot first aid
don't require high skill power in order
to get the most out of them the skill
power variation can run support skills
like tactical pulse smart cover and
support station if you don't have a six
piece final measure set a three piece
final measure to piece technicians and a
ninja buck bag will still be quite
effective however if you do have the six
PS final measure you'll get even more
support out of the set each grenade you
catch will provide a considerable buff
to your team with EMP and chakra nodes
providing a 40 percent skill power buff
frag and fire grenades giving a 40
percent whip and damage increase and
flashbang integrin AIDS increasing your
armor by 40 percent this is a fun
support build for the whole team if you
haven't tried it out I recommend it the
sentries call set makes for a pretty
average DPS bills but a fairly decent
DPS support build the four piece bonus
states head shots using semi-automatic
weapons mark the enemy increasing the
damage inflicted on the target by 5% a
target can receive up to three marks the
six piece bonus adds to this by making
it so that targets can now be marked up
to six times and the every mark after
the first one has a chance to spread
marks to other nearby NPCs at six marks
the damage on target is increased to
100% I'm expecting a little bit of salt
on this one but with the set you can
only use semi-automatic weapons these
include marksman rifles pistols and
weapons like the urban MDR but my take
on this set is that an order for you to
get the maximum out of the set you need
to shoot a target six times in the head
and when the DPS build I'd like to think
that you'd need far less than six shots
to the head to kill the target
especially if you're using a marksman
rifle so for this reason I see the
sentries call set as being better suited
and assist
your team in doing more damage rather
than attempting to take them down on
your own try to speak more into
electronics opening up a wider range of
support skills you can use a weapon with
cool-headed synergizes really well with
this build focus more on marking
multiple targets than trying to take
them down on your own don't get me wrong
I love seeing the crazy high DPS numbers
coming off targets when you get to six
stacks but with a decent sniper build
you should be able to take down most
enemies in the game with one two three
hit shots fire Crist is all about fire
in particular the fire turret although a
fairly reliable solo builds it's still a
bit slow with the damage of a time to be
considered a DPS build for the team
again the six piece - thus it is pretty
meant so running the four piece with two
technicians or the five piece with an
inventor vague or barracks chests are a
good alternative because of your
reliance on the turret I'd probably
recommend stacking into electronics but
an exotic like the urban MDR can still
have you're doing quite a bit of damage
as well
your primary skill should obviously be
the flame turret but your secondary
skill is a bit more flexible to continue
with the fire damage theme you may
choose to use air burst seeker mines
this is one of those gray area sets
although this is a fantastic solo set
and would primarily come under the tank
role the increased threat alone has this
drawing enemy fire away from your
squishier teammates allowing them to
spend more time focusing on the NPCs and
less time on their own health on top of
this the six piece set bonus offers a
buff to your team after receiving a
certain amount of damage to the shield
physical damage weapons etc will
increase armor by 30%
an exotic damage grenades will give a
30% increase to weapon damage you can
actually prop the second one on your own
by just throwing a couple of grenades at
your feet the ballistic shield is our
given but I found the bill to be pretty
effective at being the team Reviver to
equip the defib skill and keep your
teammates alive for days you're
basically a great big walking bullet
sponge that fires out magical healing
projectiles
I wanted to show some of the lesser
talked about sets here and how they can
still be quite useful when placed in the
right situation I'm really just talking
about some of the basic support sets
here and there are a ton of different
options that you could speak other sets
into but if you're one of those players
that prefers to play the support role in
the team there are certainly a number of
different options for you to try out so
what's your favorite support role to
play
are you the team healer do you like
adding buffs while still being able to
put out a bit of weapon damage or are
you the player that helps keep the more
emotionally fragile team members from
losing this [ __ ] every time they get
ganked in the dark zone let me know
below Cheers
[Music]